i think as uh president biden
highlighted there are uh official
processes around determinations of
genocide but i think it's absolutely
right that more and more people be
talking uh and using the word genocide
uh in terms of what uh russia is doing
what vladimir putin has done the use of
targeted attacks against civilians
against hospitals against maternity
wards against train stations filled with
people fleeing the deliberate use of
sexual violence
against the ukrainian population
as a way of creating
creating
horrific scenes
the way
that they're attacking ukrainian
identity and culture these are all
things that are war crimes that putin is
responsible for these are all things
that are crimes against humanity and
that's why canada was one of the first
countries to move forward at the
international criminal court to hold
vladimir putin and his cronies
responsible
for what's going on in the illegal
invasion of ukraine and
we're also dispatching rcmp
investigators to make sure that the full
truth is known and that putin be held
fully to account
i think
the moment the vladimir putin decided to
pursue his illegal invasion of ukraine
that started in crimea many years ago
but
to move on kiev
we
as
democratic countries as nato
stood up with some of the strongest
economic sanctions that anyone had ever
seen against a major economy and what
that is having is an impact on the
russian economy on vladimir putin and
his cronies is massive and not only did
we bring them in swiftly in an
incredibly united way
but we are ready to hold them as long as
we need
for the coming months the coming years
if necessary to make sure that vladimir
putin
loses in this attack on ukraine because
it's not just an attack on ukraine it's
an attack on the values that underpin
our free and democratic societies that
underpin the united nations and the rule
of law around the world that's why the
world has responded so strongly
to this invasion because it's not just
about ukraine it's also about all of us
and the values that we stand for within
our societies that's why we stepped up
not just with economic sanctions but
with direct military support for the
ukrainian military so that they
can
go
and defend their their land their
territory their values their culture
their language against these russian
invaders we're there for humanitarian
support we're there for refugee support
we're there for economic support of the
ukrainian state we're going to continue
to stand strongly every single day to
demonstrate that putin made a terrible
mistake with his choice to invade
ukraine at the same time as we make sure
that this conflict doesn't spread
around the world we need to make sure we
keep it focused on ukraine and continue
to support ukraine with everything we
have